if the writers and I'll say along with
it the directors and the actors have to
work so hard and get paid as little as
possible in order to bring these things
through to fruition that's not good for
the ecological atmosphere of the Arts
and Sciences Strikes used to happen
because a new thing was coming down the
pike everybody could say with some
degree of Truth religion well we're not
sure actually how this is going to pan
out I don't think that's the case right
now uh the economic picture is I think
relatively obvious of where it's where
it is look is it right that somebody can
create a series or direct a series or
star in a series that is spread out so
far and wide that you end up working for
a lot less money for something that is
actually profitable it has to be worked
out and it has to be worked out in an
ecumenical way in which we understand
that guys We're All in This Together